dame and um matt hancock
uh told us this morning that he didn't
quite know
where we were didn't quite know about
the impact
of the india variant what what are you
making of it
well i agree with him that we need more
data and this next week's going to be
absolutely critical
in obtaining that data one of the things
that we always have is after the
opening up of a lock down there's always
a delay
between lifting restrictions and then
the emergence of
as we might expect more infection as
people mix together more
and then whether or not that feeds
through to severe disease
and death now what we have in addition
to that mix is of course
the arrival of this delta variant which
we do understand is more transmissible
and we have seen in the last week or two
a significant uptick in the number of
cases from what was a very low base
what we need to understand is whether
what the risks are of that
setting off a another uh wave of
infection
and also how how well we can do in
controlling it so the data that comes
through
in the next week are very important and
just to remind you that with the road
map
one of the key ideas that we should
always have a significant period
of five weeks between each of the stages
was to do exactly that
because of this difficult issue of the
delay between opening up and then
understanding the impact on transmission
but clearly
this new more transmissible variant does
uh
create new challenges for us we have got
some data and we know that there is an
uptick in
infections but we also know that
hospitalizations are pretty much flat
should we be more worried
about the rise in infections or more
reassured
by the lack of an increase in
uh in hospitalizations well i think what
is reassuring
about the cases that we're seeing if you
look at the age distribution of them
overall we're seeing a much lower
proportion in the highly vaccinated
population that is the over 70s
but we're seeing more infection in the
younger population
particularly uh in in young people but
also in those who
are not vaccinated now i've just said
that it takes some time to feed through
from infections
into hospitalizations and deaths now it
is reassuring
that we haven't seen yet an uptick in
the
in the uh in the um number of admissions
and deaths
but we are so three weeks now from
the last opening up and when you think
about it it takes
a week for virus transmission to
increase because the incubation period
and then it's often another week or two
before people come into hospital after
the infection so we need to watch very
carefully
what the outcomes are but we do know of
course that the highest levels of
protection
are now the the 50 percent of people who
now have had both doses
are going to be in the more vulnerable
groups so hopefully we'll see
a a continued unlinking but we do need
to think
about the fifty percent who aren't fully
vaccinated
amen but is is there um is there
a risk that the government could find
itself
in a hole here where it appears to have
moved the goal posts
uh six months or a year ago we were all
worried
about hospitalizations and deaths it
feels now
as though the conversation is much more
about
just in fact not just but about
infections
um is there a danger that what people
will feel is
we sacrificed we stayed at home we
complied
because we didn't want to overwhelm the
nhs
we now know that's not going to happen
but now you've given us a new target
which is don't get infected
and we have to comply and stay at home
for that
is there a concern here that we might
appear to be moving the goal posts i i
totally understand your concern
you know in the end we're going to have
to if you heard earlier from david
navarro
live with this virus and try and
minimize the amount of severe disease
that it causes
but we still got i think quite a lot
more to gain
from this virus from sorry from the
vaccination program
there's you know we've still got quite a
significant number of
more many more people millions more
people who can fully benefit
from this vaccine and i think that is
that is the very
difficult decision we certainly don't
want to go on delaying
uh you know delaying forever it's going
to be a very finely judged decision
when we see um see these results so one
of the issues of course as you know we
are getting millions probably about
um uh three million people getting their
second dose
each week and another uh three million
or so getting second dose or a first
dose each week
but as we know there's a delay between
getting the dose and being fully
protected
so i think that's the very fine balance
the modelers in may
showed you could set off you know quite
a third wave and that was quite
very that is very dependent both on how
transmissible the variant is
and the fraction of people who are fully
vaccinated so the third one had all
those things
sorry so a third wave in your mind is
still
plausible well i think the the size of
i mean depends how you define a wave you
know um
and i think the model i mean this is
again we we have a lot of uncertainties
but the modelers looked at this back in
may
and there were concerns about this i
haven't seen the latest modeling because
now we've got much more data about the
vaccine uptake
and the effectiveness and so on um so i
think you have to
consider that the vaccine the vaccine
does two things
it reduces the risk of disease and it
reduces the risk of transmission
so you want to make sure that you're
getting you know
using it as much as you can and we've
got i think we've got a lot more benefit
still to get from it as we continue
uh to roll it out um and the question
the big question really
is the extent to which we see
the extent of transmission with this
this new variant
and also whether it does translate into
further admissions now
i think we're going to have to look at
that very carefully in the coming week
because of exactly the delays i've
talked and talked about and looked at
the data including the modeling the
newer modelling